Wake the fuck up the Americans.
I'm here to talk some sense into you.
Well,
hold on a second.
I'm Canadian and when I say Americans,
I'm including Canadians in that because
Canadians admitted we're really just the
51st state.
We're like California with Igloos.
So Canadians,
Americans,
same thing anywhere.
What was I saying?
We've got the Americans.
I'm here to talk some sense into you as
a nation.
We suck with languages.
43% of all people around the world are
bilingual.
That includes over 50% of the people in
Europe and in some countries like
Indonesia and Philippines,
virtually everybody is bilingual and
it's very common in a lot of countries
for people to speak three,
four,
or even five languages on a regular
basis.
But in America,
only 20% of the people are bilingual.
And guess what?
Almost all of those people are
immigrants or the children of immigrants
amongst homegrown Americans,
very few are bilingual.
And in the northern province of Canada
at the situation is not much different.
Most of the people who are bilingual are
immigrants or Francophone Canadians,
French speaking,
Canadians,
anglophone.
Canadians are generally modeling.
You will,
very few of them are bilingual.
In Australia,
the numbers are even worse.
And in Europe,
guests which countries have the lowest
levels of bilingualism?
So at the point I'm making is that
angler phones basically do not become
bilingual.
I don't want to say that anglophones are
lazy,
but why the hell are we so damn lazy?
Well,
obviously it's because of a lack of
incentive.
English is the international language.
So why should I put in all this time and
effort to speak another language when
other people will just speak English
with me?
Isn't it Kinda sorta arrogant to expect
all the other people to put in all the
effort to accommodate us?
Anybody who has traveled has probably
seen Americans or other anglophones
getting frustrated with the locals when
they couldn't speak English.
But if those anglophones had ever
learned a second language for
themselves,
maybe they would be able to understand
and empathize with that other person and
find a way to communicate with them.
The truth is English is not spoken by
most people in the world despite the
fact that it's the de facto
international language.
Most people simply don't speak English
unless you stick to the men tourist
traps and who likes cheesy tourist
traps.
Knowing another major language can
greatly help you communicate around the
world.
If there's also no guarantee that
English will be the international
language for much longer.
Not too long ago,
the international language was French,
and in the future,
maybe it will be Chinese or Spanish.
Who knows?
Well,
it probably won't be Chinese,
but you never know.
The number of Spanish speakers is
growing rapidly,
and a lot of Spanish speaking countries
are in the process of developing
rapidly.
So Spanish could become much more
important than the near future.
But even if.